paul apparence physique à l'intérieur du
salon oh oui très important surtout que
les femmes tilt je suis bien washing on
vit vous d'avoir ma voiture je sors tous
les jours de ma bulle
[Musique]
ça me stimule j'aime quand ça rouspète
on a envie de faire de jolies choses
parce qu'on est entouré de jolies femmes
ça donne une ambiance formidable c'est
parait pas une ambiance un tout petit
peu superficiel cette ambiance de beauté
de beauté tout porter sur l'apparence
physique des gens oui mais j'aime bien
ce soit complètement fou un peu c'est
juste une annonce de tout affect ris je
ne sais pas mais j'aime beaucoup
si vous n'aviez pas été communiqué au
théâtre comédia votre voiture c'est quoi
c'est une porsche
j'ai mes livres sur trois fils oui
j'aime bien géré mon nom je voudrais une
ferrari mais j'espère avoir bientôt mai
j'aime bien la porsche vous gagnez vos
goûts large oui il faut pas trop
claude à 25 ans on est un peu surpris au
fond de l'avoir déjà si dure si
peut-être un peu prématurément vieilli
toutes les coiffeuses non pas une
situation privilégiée comme elle dans un
salon privilégiées
toutes n'ont pas non plus une voiture de
sport pour dépenser l'argent qu'elle
gagne vous savez c'est un jardin parce
que ça vous donne des possibilités
d'expression c'est pas un métier
vêtements mais non pas du tout bon amant
j'ai toujours l'impression n'importe
comment que j'avais pas rester est ce
que j' étais vous voyez ce que je fais
mais c'est pas pour moi ça me ça me
suffisait pas j'ai toujours l'impression
d'avoir congé mais j'arrive à autre
chose payer et vous pensiez que la
coiffure c'était un moyen d'arriver
géorgie pour penser du tout nouveau
bureau
non pas du tout c'est venu par la suite
comme ça c'était une coïncidence poids
mais au début lorsque je mets beaucoup
de métier j'ai toujours voulu coiffeuse
mans
est ce que c'est votre ambition d'avoir
votre propre salon dans quelques
semaines et d'un socialiste au monde
les coiffeuses sous conditions
j'aimerais que vous me parler un petit
peu aussi de vos rapports avec l'argent
parce que finalement vous gagner
beaucoup d'argent
vous avez maintenant vos billets de cent
cinquante mille francs par mois c'est
beaucoup
est ce que ça ne vous pose pas de
problèmes sociaux dans vos rapports avec
les gens peut-être par exemple dans vos
rapports avec les hommes arrivent avec
des fiancés oui c'est à dire que vous
voyez maintenant je ne pourrais pas
me marier avec un homme qui gagne
maintenant veiller
c'est pour moi ça m'a baissera mes yeux
mais n'avait pas peur qui élève une
sorte de rupture jeudi rentrer ce que
vous êtes et ce que vous faites et à
monsieur qui comme beaucoup d'argent ça
peut être un monsieur qui est médecin ou
avocat est quelque chose de jean est ce
que vous vous sentirez parfaitement à
l'aise avec le monsieur qui serait un
médecin ou avocat
non je crois pas mais je pourrais pas je
crois que je peux je crois que je
courais maï maï calendrier par exemple
et je crois comme je serais gêné avec un
avec un avocat ou un mec ça y est et
avec un ouvrier vous seriez gêné parce
que je serais gêné jeteurs que je crois
que qui pourrait m'intéresser maintenant
c'est ridicule on n'encaisse pas c'est
un niveau toutefois plus parvenu à un
certain stade de russie professionnels
ont un point commun elles ne juge pas
l'univers dans lequel elles vivent elles
y sont totalement intégrés ça ne leur
paraît line superficielle ni anormal
pour avoir un vrai jugement et sur les
clientes et sur les coiffeuses
il faut une apprentie une fille jeune
avec un oeil neuf nous allons voir
marianne qui a 17 ans et qui est à la
fois révolté est fasciné par cet univers
de femmes auxquelles elle participe
quel âge aviez-vous quand vous avez
comme de 15 ans votre travail d'un jour
nos salons en quoi consistait ce qu'est
ce que j'apprends et je suis apprenti
six tentes vous avez un contrat
d'apprentissage est un contrat de trois
ans à compter mois que votre travail
on apprend tout ou pas ses épingles
l'on dégage le clientes ont fini on
termine dès muc
on n'a pas un petit peu l'impression
d'être femme de ménage mais enfin parce
que quelque chose est sûre nous est ce
que c'est des années très désagréable
toute façon je sais qu'il faut passer
par là on a trois ans à subir et de
comme l'esclave de quelqu'un mais après
l'escapade de quelqu'un c'est être
l'esclave de la coiffeuse sous les
ordres lesquels vous travaillez ou des
clients des deux
et quelle le maître le plus désagréable
la coiffeuse mec-là clients pourquoi
certains débats gré à ces bananes tous
ces banalités ce qu'elles peuvent
raconter
est ce qu'elles vous donnent des armes
parce qu'elle vous demande de faire des
choses qui vous déplaisent à accrocher
leurs manteaux et ça c'est leur vie et
ça ça vous est pris à moi j'aime pas
rendre service
est ce que vous n'avez pas l'impression
qu'à force de vivre dans un univers de
femmes n'y a que des femmes soucieux de
leur beauté on se met à les détester
vous n'avez jamais si je les déteste
beaucoup oui en bloc
oui
[Musique]